I got in so much trouble on Twitter over
the weekend
for saying something
that is just obviously true
here's what I said I don't I don't want
to
misquote Myself by even one syllable I
said
unpopular opinion
civil leaders do in fact have emergency
authority to suspend temporarily many
legal rights
that's true so my point being that the
New Mexico Governor is wrong in
particular here one because as that
reporter pointed out the criminals
aren't going to stop carrying their guns
because of this emergency declaration
two because the uh people of New Mexico
the law-abiding people of New Mexico
actually need a gun more than ever they
need to be able to carry a gun more than
ever because of the insane amount of
crime in Albuquerque and three because
the incident that took place in the road
rage though tragic does not constitute
an emergency so that's the reason why
what she did is wrong but she's only
wrong in particular she's not wrong in
principle and conservatives oddly enough
seem to be misunderstanding this but the
point I was making
that civil leaders have emergency
Authority temporarily to suspend rights
that is not a particularly controversial
point of view I mean I guess it is now
but it has never been controversial
throughout all of American History
throughout all of the political history
of the entire West
on on either side of the aisle or any of
the the different political uh
participants in our country the the
basic principle has often been
articulated in America as the
Constitution is not a suicide pact
in other words
all legal rights are important the law
is very important up to and including
the Constitution but when the whole of
the law is threatened then a rigorous
meticulous adherence to the letter of
every single individual aspect of the
law is actually going to undermine the
law because you could lose the whole law
in the whole political order to Anarchy
or to I don't know an Insurrection or an
invasion I guess those would be the
extreme cases where I think everybody
has to Grant my point if the United
States were suddenly invaded well I
guess we are being invaded if the United
States were being more obviously invaded
and there there were or there were a
major Insurrection not some Midwestern
grannies at the Capitol but an actual
insurrection
would would martial law for instance be
called for
yes of course
would you would you rather throw away
your whole system of law because you're
going to uphold every single little
statute everywhere or no would you take
care of the problem and then bring back
the law
I think we all agree if martial law is a
thing that exists and has been exercised
a number of times in American history by
some presidents who would like some
presidents who we don't like then
the principle holds true
you wouldn't want to give away the whole
of the law a good piece of evidence that
my view is not so crazy is that Ted Lou
who's one of the most lib frustrating
members of Congress out there tweeted
out he said this order from the governor
of New Mexico violates the Constitution
no state in the Union can suspend the
Federal Constitution there's no such
thing as a state public health emergency
except to the U.S constitute exception
to the U.S Constitution so Ted lose
saying no no we have to always
rigorously follow the letter of the law
I guess Ted Lou now supports concealed
carry that's great I don't I didn't
think he did but I guess he says that he
he does now David Hogg who's that like
12 year old I think now he's like 30 but
he started out when he was 12. David
Hogg is this anti-gun campaigner says I
support gun safety there's no such thing
as a state public health emergency
exception to the U.S Constitution
so the fact that two huge Libs are on
one side of the issue and I a
conservative or on the other side of the
issue some people took this to to mean
that the world has gone crazy and can
you believe it even David Hogg even Ted
Lou no they're they hold this view
because they are liberals because
they're extreme liberals
and I hold this view because I am a
conservative this view though has been
held by conservatives by liberals by
everyone going back Thomas Jefferson
probably said it most clearly
Thomas Jefferson wrote in 1807 on great
occasions every good officer must be
ready to risk himself in going beyond
the strict line of the law when the
public preservation requires it his
motives will be his justification pretty
that's a pretty strong statement his
motives will be his justification there
are extreme cases where the laws become
inadequate to their own preservation and
where the universal recourse is a
dictator or martial law so lest there be
any confusion as to how far Thomas
Jefferson who is probably our most uh
open-minded classically liberal founding
father he said No at certain points if
the whole of the law is threatened if
the whole of the nation is threatened
then you've got to take care of the
emergency and then go back to the law
Jefferson went on further a strict
observance of the written laws is
doubtless one of the high duties of a
good citizen but it is not the highest
the laws of necessity of
self-preservation of saving our country
when in danger are of a higher
obligation to lose our country by a
scrupulous adherence to written law
would be to lose the law itself this is
almost exactly what I just said with
life liberty property and all those who
are enjoying them with us thus absurdly
sacrificing the end to the means and
Jefferson finally says the line of
discrimination because some people are
going to say well how do you know when
it's really emergency how do you know
this won't be exploited Jefferson
addresses this he says the line of
discrimination between cases may be
difficult but the good officer is bound
to draw it at his own Peril and throw
himself on the justice of his country
and the rectitude of his motives wasn't
just Jefferson John
Hamilton and Madison made similar points
in the Federalist John Adams exercised a
not not quite a suspension of the law
but a a strong uh circumscription of the
law in the Alien and Sedition Acts a
strong curtailing or limiting of the
First Amendment uh you saw obviously
Abraham Lincoln suspended habeas corpus
uh generally we like atoms I think most
people like Abraham Lincoln that's been
used by bad presidents too uh Franklin
Roosevelt and Woodrow Wilson but it's
been used a lot we we've had martial law
declared in the United States on a
number of occasions because of war in
the case of the City of New Orleans
during the Battle of New Orleans we've
had it declared during uh natural
disasters a great Chicago fire
1871. there are some other ones 1906 San
Francisco earthquake Omaha race riot
2019-20 Lexington riots so where does
this idea come from it goes back even
earlier than Thomas Jefferson it goes
back to this notion that the the welfare
of the people the good of the people
is the highest law salus populi suprema
lacks this is a law that comes from
Cicero in ancient Rome Cicero on the
laws but it was re-articulated by none
other than John Locke the father of
liberalism Classical liberalism a man
who was fairly influential though his
influence has been exaggerated but
fairly influential in the American
Revolution he wrote this as the epigraph
to his Second Treatise on government
this is John Locke's most famous book
he said that this is a fundamental rule
for government that is the highest point
of the law right now text Knowles to 98
98 98 Vladimir Putin called the US
Dollars drop in dominance objective and
irreversible
it's not a great Russian Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa formally
have agreed to use local currencies in
trade instead of the US dollar as demand
for the dollar weakens the buying power
of the dollar weakens this is why Birch
gold is busier than ever investors and
Savers are looking to harness the power
of physical gold sheltered in attacks
sheltered Ira you can protect your IRA
or 401K by diversifying with gold from
Birch gold as the U.S dollar continues
to receive pressure from foreign
countries digital currency and central
banks arm yourself with information on
how to protect your savings learn if
gold is right for you too text Knowles
kwles to 98 98 98 they will send you a
free info kit on gold with an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
of thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews I trust
Birch gold to help you diversify into
gold if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have some gold to depend upon text
Knowles Canada be Valley Esther 98 98 98
some people point out they say well
Michael where in the Constitution
doesn't say that there's an exception to
this
first of all it's alluded to in uh in at
least two parts of the Constitution but
even let's go beyond that for a second
if the exception were included within
the text of the statute the law of the
Constitution it would not constitute a
true exception we're talking about
something at a higher level than than
the mere text that's what Jefferson's
talking about that's what John Locke is
talking about here that's what Cicero is
talking about
and in fact this principle has been
upheld by the Supreme Court or at least
articulated by the Supreme Court on at
least two occasions explicitly in 1949
and 1963 Supreme Court decisions
explicitly said the Constitution is not
a suicide pact so why do I bring it up
because I said at the beginning I'm not
bringing it up to justify the New Mexico
Governor's actions I said in the case of
what she's done this is wrong
but it's wrong for different reasons
than we conservatives are saying
and I think that I think the reason that
Ted Lou and David Hogg are on one side
of this argument and I'm on the other is
not because the world has gone crazy but
it's because
the Liberals don't want conservatives to
recognize this point that when the whole
of the law is threatened it is not only
our right but it is our responsibility
to in certain narrow extreme cases go
beyond the mere letter of the law to
save the whole of it the the most
perspicacious response to my I thought
basically uncontroversial point on uh
Twitter was that they said wow it was a
liberal who said it Wilbur said this New
Mexico Governor's decision was so
moronic because it's going to empower
conservatives to begin to exercise this
line of thinking and I think that's the
point
we conservatives
in traditionally have always been pretty
practical you know pretty grounded in
reality pretty focused on tradition and
history and how the law actually works
in the last few decades we've gotten
very ideological we've taken a ton of
bait from the Liberals and so now we
speak in these abstract rights almost
exclusively and in a way that's a
historical and in a way that is not very
effective because we can whine and
scream and we say this is hypocrisy that
what she's doing this is
unconstitutional this isn't right we
have our rights and that's going to be
the Epitaph on the gravestone of
conservatism imagine if the shoe were on
the other foot imagine if we did this
well no she in principle her point is
right
and we should fight her on the
particulars this is not an emergency
this is not going to help anything this
we should fight her in court I don't
think this thing is going to hold up
and then we should also exercise the
correct principle that she is here
exercising in what case would you say we
would do that well I mentioned earlier
that an invasion would be a good example
of a time when we could uh go a little
beyond the ordinary operation of the law
because an invasion threatens our entire
political order threatens the whole of
the law
unfortunately we have not been able to
stop the Invasion on our Southern border
because every time even Donald Trump
who's really relatively strong on this
when he would try
all of a sudden
the the mechanisms of the bureaucracy
and the supposed meaning of the strict
letter of the law said no you can't stop
an invasion of foreigners into your
country now Trump managed to get around
this one time and you know how he did it
by curtailing and suspending the
ordinary operation of the law through
title 42. he said okay the libs are
going to declare an emergency with kovid
I'm going to use that emergency with
covid to greatly reduce the flow of
illegal immigrants into the country
very important and then the Biden
Administration runs and they say we're
going to get rid of that title 42.
perhaps if conservatives
would stop believing a bunch of hogwash
about American history I mean the notion
that so many conservatives didn't
understand that the constitution is not
a suicide pact tells me that even on the
right forget about the people on the
left who are very confused about
American history even many people on the
right believe a whole thought a lot of
things about American history and
government and political philosophy that
just aren't true a lot of us believe
fairy tales that were invented in the
middle of the 20th century but America
is a fundamentally liberal democracy and
America how we there isn't there are no
complications to any of our abstract
rights or anything like that that it's
just not true
and it has really hampered our ability
to wield political power effectively
this woman knows how to wield political
power
now I think she's gone too far I think
she's wrong in the particulars I think
this is gonna I don't think she'll be
able to extend this after 30 days she
might not even be able to make it the
full 30 days and even if she does it'll
be litigated in court it's a it's a one
aspect of par of a hotly debated at part
of the second amendment I don't think
this is going to be the end of the world
for New Mexico
it's a stupid decision but it's not
going to be the end of the world but the
principle that she's articulating if we
were to accept it would perhaps allow us
to get around the very unjust wielding
of the strict letter of the law on
legitimate National emergencies I'll
leave my point
at that boy what a great clip that was
now up but make sure that you ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
podcast
we'll see you next time